STEPHANIE WONG: With almost
500 sessions on Next 2019,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see the
high performance network,
then stay tuned because
here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's no surprise that
Google serves billions
of search query answers
and hours of YouTube videos
to users all over the world.
But what really
powers this ability
is the network that
allows us to replicate
content and services globally.
And it's also the network
that powers Google Cloud.
The big question is how we
built the underlying physical
and operating aspects
of this network
to build for resilience.
Let's first talk about our
global physical network.
Over the last 20
years, Google has
built an extensive network
connecting continents
using submarine cables.
In fact, one of our
new undersea cables
between Sydney and Singapore
has cut network latency in half.
Planning and building
our own submarine cables
means we can build a
level of path certainty
and predictability of
network traffic performance.
These paths are private,
and Google implements this
through our consortium
of partners.
This means that
Google Cloud customers
are able to connect to
this network at locations
all over the world.
How do we plan for resilience?
We do extensive simulations
when deciding to add new network
capacity and make sure
it's not affecting
our SLOs in a negative way.
We use trended historical
data on outages,
and then classify
different failure types
across the entire network
path, and run them
for a fictional 20, 30, 40, 50
years across a range of network
paths.
This gives us a reasonably
high degree of certainty
that the network we choose
and the additional capacity
locations and paths
we add will increase
the resilience and
the predictability
that we care so much about.
These simulations
mean we can be sure we
are avoiding any negative impact
for Google Cloud customers.
How do we operate in
a resilient manner?
We've been operating a
software defined network
across our core
data center network.
We're now extending that
out to the very edge
with the announcement of
Espresso a couple of years ago.
This enables us to maintain
a level of performance
and availability right
out to the edge, which
isn't possible using
regular routing protocols
and approaches.
At the Edge Network,
we can connect
with nearly all significant
network operators, which
allows handoff of
network traffic directly
and reliably to
99% of our traffic.
We also have network
site reliability teams
stationed around the world.
Their role is to respond
and adapt to network events
to improve systems and
processes so reliability
and performance of network
continues to improve over time.
When an issue occurs,
they identify root causes
and implement new workarounds.
In other words, they're
here as first responders
to make sure Google
Cloud customers have
a consistent and
reliable experience.
Now, there's always a risk of
bad actors or network exposure.
Google is continually
enhancing our own monitoring
and filtering capabilities
to get quicker and better.
Because this is a
community-wide issue,
we have a new
partnership with MANRS,
which is a Mutually Agreed Norms
for Routing Security, where
we are working to enhance
the security of routing
on the internet.
If you're wondering
about how Google designed
its strong network
backbone, we've
built a software defined
network from the ground up.
Our first iteration was B4, a
massive backbone between all
of our data centers.
We then introduced Jupiter,
which is our massive switching
fabric that goes
within our data centers
and makes tens of
thousands of machines
act together as one big system.
Andromeda, the network software
defined at the virtualization
layer that Google
Cloud customers use
to build Cloud resources
and Espresso are taking SDN
capabilities out to the edge.
All of these components have
helped us scale and deliver
traffic for Google products,
like Search and YouTube.
And these are the same building
blocks that Google Cloud
customers get to use too.
Now, there is a
ton more they cover
in the talks about
the protocols we
use to improve performance,
our global load
balancer, virtual private cloud,
and logging and monitoring.
So check out the full talk in
the link in the description
below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]